Aujourd'hui à l'émission :
un grand dossier sur l'état
de santé des océans.
Malmenés par les changements
climatiques et la surpêche,
pris d'assaut par la pollution
aux plastiques, comment
se portent les océans et les
êtres vivants qui les habitent?
(chant de baleine)
Bonjour, bienvenue à La semaine
verte.  Ça peut sembler étonnan,
mais notre survie dépend
de la santé des océans.
Les services qu'ils nous
rendent sont immenses.
Ils nous nourrissent, ils sont
aussi d'importants régulateurs
du climat. Mais les océans
sont malades, et les maux
qui les affligent ne cessent
de prendre de l'ampleur. Alors,
est-il trop tard pour agir?
Y a-t-il raison d'espérer?
Voici un bilan de santé
des océans.
- (narrateur): La Terre...
la planète bleue.
C'est ici que nous habitons.
Huit milliards d'humains y
vivent, entourés d'eau salée.
Des océans, essentiels à la vie,
et qui sont de plus en plus
fragilisés.
À tel point que notre existence
sur cette planète pourrait bien
ne plus jamais être comme avant.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Je crois que je suis
optimiste, mais quand il
s'agit de l'océan aujourd'hui,
je suis inquiète.
(bruit de la mise à feu)
- Peu d'entre nous ont observé
la Terre comme Kathy Sullivan.
Cette astronaute américaine
est aussi océanographe.
Et le regard qu'elle porte
sur notre planète est unique.
- J'avais l'impression
simultanément de fragilité et
de pouvoir de notre planète.
♪ ♪ ♪
On voit des orages très
grands ou des courants
océanographiques, des centaines
de kilomètres; simultanément
la fragilité, l'élégance et
le pouvoir. Grand pouvoir.
(bruit de la vague)
On a donné à cette planète
le mauvais nom. On l'a nommée
Terre. On aurait dû la nommer
Aqua.
- Aqua, c'est le mot latin pour
eau. Et il y en a à la grandeur
du globe : 71 % de la surface de
la Terre est recouverte par des
océans qui sont interconnectés.
Cela représente un volume
immense de 1,37 milliard de
kilomètres cubes d'eau salée
encore très largement
inexplorée.
♪ ♪ ♪
Beaucoup reste encore à
découvrir. Plus de 90 % des
espèces présentes dans les
océans n'auraient pas encore été
répertoriées. Il y a de la vie
partout, autant dans la colonne
d'eau que sur les fonds marins;
du plateau continental, près
des rives, au plus profond des
fosses abyssales; des organismes
microscopiques, jusqu'aux plus
grands êtres vivants. Cet énorme
garde-manger nourrit les humains
depuis la nuit des temps.
Et les scientifiques
d'aujourd'hui croient même
pouvoir y trouver les remèdes
aux maladies de demain.
- L'océan, pour moi, ça
représente la vie. C'est à cause
de l'océan de cette planète
que nous vivons. La moitié de
l'oxygène que nous respirons,
ça vient direct de l'océan.
- En plus d'être notre
principale source d'oxygène,
les océans influencent largement
le climat de la planète.
Ils absorbent la chaleur de
l'atmosphère et sont aussi
de véritables puits qui
capturent le gaz carbonique.
Mais malgré leur grande
résilience, les océans sont
à bout de souffle, et ce n'est
pas une bonne nouvelle.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Alors pour moi, ça a renforcé
une obligation de me souvenir
que je suis connectée richement,
connectée avec toutes parts
de cette planète. Il me faut
bien la soigner, c'est la seule
planète qu'on a.
- Kathy Sullivan n'est pas
la seule à sonner l'alarme.
En 2019, le Groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat, le GIEC,
a déposé un rapport spécial sur
l'océan lors d'une conférence
à Monaco. Son constat a de quoi
faire frémir :
- En tant qu'espèce, les humains
sont en train de modifier les
océans de telle façon qu'on
risque de vraiment leur nuire
au niveau de la biodiversité et
l'abondance de plusieurs espèces
de poissons et d'invertébrés
marins.
- Au Québec, le physicien
Denis Gilbert est inquiet.
Le chercheur à l'Institut
Maurice-Lamontagne a fait partie
de la délégation canadienne
qui a travaillé à l'adoption
du rapport du GIEC à Monaco.
- Ma réaction principale par
rapport au rapport, c'est qu'il
est plus que temps que les
humains prennent en contrôle
leurs émissions de gaz à effet
de serre. Avec les niveaux de
CO2 actuels qui continuent
d'augmenter parce qu'on utilise
encore énormément de charbon,
de gaz naturel et de pétrole,
la tendance lourde actuelle
me force à être pessimiste.
(échanges radio)
- Le système climatique de la
Terre est régi principalement
par les échanges d'énergie
entre l'océan et l'atmosphère.
Avec l'augmentation du CO2,
la température de la planète
se réchauffe, entraînant
aussi la hausse des océans.
Et cela provoque son lot
de bouleversements.
Peter Galbraith est un peu
comme un docteur au chevet
d'un malade. Son patient :
le grand système que constitue
le Saint-Laurent.
- Donc, il y a à peu près une
dizaine d'années, les choses
ont commencé à vraiment changer
dans le golfe Saint-Laurent,
où mon rôle est devenu beaucoup
plus important dans le sens
où il se passe quelque chose
dans le golfe Saint-Laurent,
il faut pas le manquer.
- Le chercheur à l'Institut
Maurice-Lamontagne analyse
la température des eaux afin
de quantifier les changements
qui affectent les organismes
marins. Son diagnostic est
sans équivoque : depuis ces
dernières années, les eaux
du Saint-Laurent ne cessent
de se réchauffer.
- J'ai commencé 101
avec le fond.
- À chaque année, c'est un petit
peu plus chaud. Chaque année,
on brise le record, donc on est
déjà dans des températures que
le golfe, dans les 100 dernières
années, n'a pas connues.
- L'eau n'est pas homogène.
Dans le système du
Saint-Laurent, on retrouve
trois couches superposées qui
se réchauffent pour des raisons
différentes. L'enjeu en surface,
c'est la perte du couvert
de glace en hiver qu'on voit
poindre à l'horizon.
- En se projetant juste une
cinquantaine d'années dans
le futur, bien, on va voir
que le golfe Saint-Laurent
va devenir un petit peu comme
Halifax l'est maintenant,
où la glace de mer ne se rend
pas à Halifax. Ça va être la
même histoire pour le golfe
Saint-Laurent, où la glace va
se former jusqu'au plateau du
Labrador, mais on n'en verra pas
dans le golfe Saint-Laurent,
sauf exception d'années très
fortement froides.
- Peter Galbraith est
particulièrement inquiet
de ce qui arrive à la couche
d'eau profonde, là où vivent
de nombreux organismes marins.
Cette couche n'est pas en
contact avec l'atmosphère
et elle est indépendante
des couches supérieures. Sa
température est influencée par
les grands courants océaniques
de l'Atlantique qui, eux, ont
commencé à être perturbés par
les changements climatiques.
- Donc ces eaux-là nous viennent
du bout du chenal Laurentien à
l'extrémité complète, en dehors
du golfe. Puis ce mélange-là
est de plus en plus riche en eau
chaude. Donc on sait que, pour
les quelques prochaines années
à tout le moins, ça va continuer
à réchauffer. On doit s'en
inquiéter parce qu'on est sorti
de l'enveloppe du connu.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le réchauffement des océans
a un impact bien tangible sur
les humains, principalement
pour les populations côtières
et insulaires. C'est que le
niveau de l'eau s'est mis
à monter et ce phénomène
n'est pas près de s'arrêter.
- L'éléphant dans la pièce
qui fait peur à tout le monde,
c'est la fonte des calottes
glaciaires, celles du Groenland
et de l'Antarctique. Il y a
à peu près deux décennies,
ces fontes-là, au Groenland
et en Antarctique, étaient
relativement lentes, mais dans
ces deux endroits-là, il y a
une accélération du phénomène.
- Selon le GIEC, au cours du
siècle, le niveau de la mer
continuera d'augmenter comme
jamais; et cette hausse pourrait
atteindre 30 à 60 cm d'ici 2100.
Jumelée à l'intensification
des phénomènes météo extrêmes,
les conséquences seront
majeures. Plusieurs villes
côtières et des îles de faible
élévation vont y goûter,
comme à Miami dernièrement.
- La conséquence principale de
la hausse des niveaux de la mer,
c'est que plusieurs grandes
métropoles vont être affectées
et vont devoir se bâtir toutes
sortes de défenses pour protéger
les infrastructures.
- La vie d'une grande partie
de l'humanité sera chamboulée.
Environ 30 % de la population
mondiale habite à moins
de 100 km d'une côte.
- On peut s'imaginer des villes
comme Shanghai, des villes
comme New York essayer de
se protéger. Ici, la ville
de Québec est un endroit où il
va y avoir aussi des effets de
la hausse du niveau de la mer.
- Les humains auront beau
essayer de se protéger,
il y a un autre problème
auquel ils n'échapperont pas.
- Les océans nous ont offert
un grand service, à l'humanité,
c'est qu'ils absorbent une
grande partie du gaz carbonique
qu'on émet.
Mais ce service-là vient
à un coût, c'est qu'il vient
acidifier les eaux océaniques.
- Les océans absorbent plus
du quart des émissions de CO2
produites par l'homme chaque
année. Ce dioxyde de carbone
se dissout dans l'eau et
forme de l'acide carbonique.
Conséquence : son pH diminue et
l'océan s'acidifie. Un processus
qui risque de s'intensifier à
proximité de la surface, où l'on
retrouve une grande partie des
espèces exploitées par l'homme.
- On est en train de faire
une expérience avec le CO2
qui a le potentiel d'appauvrir
énormément les océans.
- Les organismes qui possèdent
une structure calcaire seraient
touchés. On pense ici au
plancton, à la base de la chaîne
alimentaire. Certains mollusques
et crustacés aussi pourraient
avoir de la difficulté à former
leur coquille et leur squelette
externe. Enfin, les coraux, qui
sont une formidable pouponnière
pour les poissons, risquent
d'avoir de plus en plus
de difficulté à survivre.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le bilan pour les océans
est sombre et les défis sont
nombreux. Arriverons-nous
à renverser la vapeur?
- Arrêter le réchauffement,
arrêter l'acidification,
pour cela, il s'agit d'arrêter
les émissions de carbone.
Voulons-nous faire cela?
C'est ça la question.
♪ ♪ ♪
On le voyait en introduction,
les océans vivent des
bouleversements sans précédent.
Mais quel est l'impact sur
les êtres vivants qui habitent
ces écosystèmes marins? À l'ère
des changements climatiques,
y a-t-il des gagnants et des
perdants? Cap sur le golfe
du Saint-Laurent.
♪ ♪ ♪
- (narrateur): Le golfe du
Saint-Laurent est une immense
mer intérieure. Dans les
villages côtiers, les bateaux
de pêche déchargent de leurs
cales des poissons, des
crustacés et des holothuries.
Mais si, à première vue,
l'activité semble prospère,
tout n'est pas rose au large.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le golfe subit les contrecoups
des bouleversements qui
secouent les océans partout
sur la planète.
Au quai de Rivière-au-Renard,
en Gaspésie, la saison de pêche
à la crevette bat son plein.
- Ils étaient ben juste sur
notre bord à nous autres.
- Comme la plupart des pêcheurs,
Mario Côté et son fils
Jean-Frédéric ont dû composer
avec les changements
qui affectent le golfe
du Saint-Laurent.
- C'est sûr que l'eau s'est
réchauffée dans le golfe,
ça, on s'en rend tous compte.
- On peut pas s'en cacher
que ça fait peur tout ce
que c'est qu'on entend,
le réchauffement... T'sais,
c'est gros! Mais c'est-tu nous
autres la solution? C'est-tu...?
Ça, je me pose la question.
- Comme les pêcheurs,
les scientifiques canadiens
se posent des questions sur
l'impact qu'a le réchauffement
des eaux sur les espèces
marines. Pour le biologiste
Hugo Bourdages, tout n'est pas
blanc ou noir dans le golfe
du Saint-Laurent.
- Oui, il y en a qui vont
s'en tirer moins bien, mais
il y en a qui vont s'en tirer...
qui vont bien s'en tirer.
- Par exemple, le homard se
porte à merveille. Par contre,
des espèces comme le crabe
des neiges, la crevette et
le turbot ont déjà de la
difficulté à s'acclimater.
- Il n'y a pas de bon et de pas
bon dans ce réchauffement-là
qu'on observe.
C'est plus un déplacement
de nos espèces dans l'espace.
Il y a plusieurs exemples
d'espèces qui se portent bien
dans cet environnement-là
qui est changeant.
- C'est le cas du sébaste,
qui est devenu le nouveau roi
du Saint-Laurent.
- En 2011, 2012 et 2013,
on ne sait pas trop pourquoi
exactement, mais on a vraiment
gagné à la loterie, à savoir
qu'on a trois cohortes
importantes de sébastes qui
sont apparues puis qui vont
bientôt rentrer à des tailles
appréciables pour la pêche
commerciale.
- Le sébaste est un poisson de
fond qui peut vivre jusqu'à
75 ans. Comme ceux de la morue,
ses stocks ont chuté de façon
dramatique dans les années 80.
À tel point qu'il a fallu
imposer un moratoire sur
sa pêche. Mais contre toute
attente, des relevés récents
au chalut ont confirmé le retour
spectaculaire du sébaste dans
le golfe du Saint-Laurent.
- L'année dernière, d'après
nos estimés, 90 % de la biomasse
qu'on a attrapée dans le fond du
golfe représentait des sébastes.
Si on compare avec le passé,
c'était plutôt 10, 15 %.
- Dans la salle des bassins de
l'Institut Maurice-Lamontagne
à Mont-Joli, les chercheurs
Caroline Senay et Denis Chabot
explorent plusieurs hypothèses
pour tenter de comprendre
le rétablissement étonnant
des populations de sébastes.
- Celle qui semble la plus
plausible est que les sébastes
sont une des rares espèces qui
tirent plutôt bien leur épingle
du jeu face aux changements
climatiques.
- Les chercheurs ont capturé
800 sébastes dans le
Saint-Laurent pour les exposer
ensuite aux variations de
température et d'acidité qui
sont anticipées dans le golfe
d'ici la fin du siècle.
- Le but du projet, c'est
de pouvoir mieux prédire
la physiologie, les besoins
énergétiques, le taux de
croissance, le taux de survie du
sébaste aux conditions actuelles
et aux conditions futures.
- Une des victimes du retour en
force du sébaste est la crevette
nordique. Après avoir atteint
des niveaux d'abondance
historiques, sa population a
fortement décliné depuis 2010.
Pas surprenant, puisque le
sébaste a fait de la crevette
une de ses principales proies.
Une chose est certaine,
il y aura des gagnants et des
perdants ici comme ailleurs. Et
il faudra se montrer résilient,
car les changements que nous
vivons sont là pour durer.
- C'est clair que le golfe
du Saint-Laurent, dans 50 ans,
va être différent de celui
d'aujourd'hui. Donc il y aura
encore une biodiversité à ce
moment-là, mais on aura perdu
l'écosystème qu'on connaît
actuellement. Et à mes yeux,
c'est une perte pour la planète
et pour nous.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ce bouleversement mondial
des écosystèmes est un enjeu
de taille. L'océan est la plus
grande source de protéines de la
planète. C'est le garde-manger
de plus de 3 milliards
d'humains. Et ce sont
les habitants des pays en
développement qui seront
les plus touchés. La raison :
le réchauffement de l'eau
provoque déjà le déplacement
de nombreuses espèces vers les
pôles et va laisser un vide
alimentaire dans les régions
tropicales.
Mais, selon certains
scientifiques, les changements
climatiques ne sont pas la seule
menace à la survie des stocks
de poissons.
- La surpêche, c'est la raison
principale du déclin de la santé
des océans parce que la surpêche
et la pêche, en fait, c'est fait
pour tuer des poissons.
- À Vancouver, au bord du
Pacifique, Daniel Pauly dresse
un constat accablant de
notre gestion des pêcheries.
Ce chercheur a consacré sa vie
à étudier l'impact des pêches
sur les stocks de poissons.
- Dans la plupart des pays,
la surpêche, c'est le résultat
d'une pêche incontrôlée.
Donc la pêche incontrôlée,
ça devient un peu une surpêche.
- Parmi les espèces qui sont
exploitées au maximum de
ce qu'elles peuvent endurer,
on pense au thon et au requin.
- La pêche ne produit rien.
La pêche ne fait que ramasser
ce que la nature produit.
Les poissons, c'est pas
le pêcheur qui les produit.
Il ne fait que les ramasser.
- Selon les chiffres recueillis
par l'ONU, 94 % des stocks de
poissons seraient à la limite
de leur exploitation ou bien
surexploités. Mais peut-être
est-ce davantage. Le problème,
c'est que trop souvent, on ne
sait pas avec précision ce que
les pêcheurs sortent de l'océan.
- La méconnaissance des prises
réelles des pêcheries mondiales
a caché une partie du déclin.
Encore aujourd'hui, on a
l'impression que les stocks se
maintiennent alors qu'en fait,
ils s'écroulent très souvent.
- Selon lui, une des solutions
pour en arriver à mettre en
place une pêche durable serait
d'arrêter de maintenir en vie
artificiellement cette activité
économique au détriment de la
ressource.
- Toute pêcherie qui a besoin
d'être subventionnée a besoin
d'être abandonnée parce qu'elle
ne devrait pas continuer.
Parce que la nature nous dit :
«Laissez-moi tranquille. Il faut
que je me repose. Il faut que
je me remette.» Et ce message
très clair que la nature
nous donne, on n'a pas besoin
de l'écouter quand on a
des subventions. Donc voilà,
on continue à pêcher malgré
le fait que les ressources
soient exterminées.
- Partout sur la planète,
les pêcheurs n'ont pas le choix;
ils devront continuer à
s'adapter.
- On va faire comme... on va
dire, comme mon père a fait
quand il a pris le bateau, comme
mon grand-père a fait aussi.
On va s'habituer avec ce
qui arrive en ce moment.
- Je peux pas croire que
du jour au lendemain, il n'y a
plus personne qui va pêcher
sur la terre. Il y a du monde
qui serait malheureux en
tabarouette. La planète au
complet est affectée là-dedans.
On a une grosse part de
responsabilité mondiale à faire,
pas juste pêcheurs. C'est
mondial que ça va être, là.
- Après la pause : le plastique
dans les océans, un fléau
aux conséquences jusqu'ici
insoupçonnées.
La pollution des océans par
le plastique est une crise
d'envergure planétaire.
Et une chercheuse québécoise
basée en Californie est arrivée
à un triste constat : en plus
de provoquer la mort de nombreux
animaux marins, le plastique,
en se dégradant dans les océans,
représente une source de gaz
à effet de serre jusqu'ici
méconnue.
♪ ♪ ♪
- (narrateur):
Chaque année, on produit
plus de 300 millions de tonnes
de plastique dans le monde.
♪ ♪ ♪
Selon une étude récente,
à peine 9 % de cette matière
serait recyclée et 12 %,
incinérée. L'immense majorité
des plastiques -- 79 % -- se
retrouve dans les dépotoirs
ou, pire encore,
dans l'environnement.
♪ ♪ ♪
Et quand on parle de rejets
dans l'environnement, ce sont
des images comme celles-ci
qui nous viennent en tête.
♪ ♪ ♪
Les scientifiques estiment
que chaque année, 8 millions
de tonnes de plastique
aboutissent dans les océans.
- Il y en a partout, du
plastique. C'est... Oui, c'est
sur toutes les plages à travers
le monde, hein! Trente secondes
de marche puis j'ai trouvé
sept items de plastique :
une bouteille de plastique,
des emballages de plastique,
des contenants. C'est triste!
♪ ♪ ♪
Il y a un énorme problème.
Il y a un problème incroyable
au niveau du plastique.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Sarah-Jeanne Royer
est océanographe.
Depuis quelques années, cette
scientifique québécoise alterne
ses recherches entre Hawaï
et San Diego, en Californie.
Sa spécialité : les effets
de la pollution des plastiques
dans l'océan.
- Aujourd'hui, l'homme menace
la santé des océans. Mais pour
moi, en tant qu'océanographe,
les océans, c'est notre
réservoir thermique. C'est la
vie. C'est ce qui nous permet
d'être au monde aujourd'hui.
Et donc, moi, je veux protéger
les océans.
L'impact du plastique sur la
santé des océans est immense.
À chaque minute, on a environ
un camion de vidange de déchets
de plastique qui est déversé
dans l'océan.
- Le plastique arrive
dans l'océan de partout
et sous plusieurs formes.
Le vent et la pluie transportent
vers les ruisseaux et
les rivières des sacs,
des bouteilles, des pailles et
une multitude d'autres objets,
pour la plupart à usage unique,
qui finissent souvent
par aboutir dans l'océan.
S'ajoutent les microplastiques,
ces particules de moins de
5 mm contenues dans les savons,
les cosmétiques et les produits
d'entretien qui sont rejetés
dans les égouts. Et c'est
sans compter toutes les bouées
et filets de pêche, faits de
matière plastique, qui sont
perdus ou abandonnés en mer.
Une fois dans l'océan,
le plastique se disperse.
Ces déchets peuvent parcourir
des milliers de kilomètres,
emportés dans le tourbillon
des courants marins,
les gyres océaniques.
On en retrouve cinq sur la
planète. Sarah-Jeanne Royer
a pu constater leur impact
sur les côtes hawaïennes.
- À Hawaï, on retrouve une
quantité phénoménale de débris
marins. Les plastiques dans la
gyre océanique peuvent résider
pendant plusieurs années, puis
vont se fragmenter. Ils vont
devenir de plus en plus petits.
Et éventuellement, quand il y a
une tempête, quand les vents
sont plus élevés, ces bouts de
plastique vont être rejetés de
la gyre et, éventuellement,
vont se retrouver sur
les plages hawaïennes.
- Et les dommages sont durables.
On estime que le plastique peut
rester dans l'environnement
durant des centaines d'années.
- Les quantités, depuis les
années 50, sont monstrueuses.
Puis ce plastique devient de
plus en plus en petits morceaux
puis accessible à de plus
en plus d'animaux marins,
plus ils sont petits. Donc, tous
les animaux qui se retrouvent
dans l'océan vont ingérer
du plastique par erreur.
- Les animaux marins, du plus
petit au plus grand, confondent
ces morceaux de plastique de
différentes tailles avec la
nourriture. Selon la Commission
océanographique de l'UNESCO,
ces débris causent annuellement
la mort d'un million d'oiseaux.
Et c'est sans compter les
100 000 mammifères marins
qui perdent la vie, empêtrés
dans des engins de pêche
faits de plastique.
Mais la pollution par les
plastiques dans les océans
risque de causer d'autres
dommages à la planète,
jusque-là insoupçonnés.
Parce que le plastique est
produit à partir de combustibles
fossiles comme le pétrole,
Sarah-Jeanne Royer s'est demandé
si sa dégradation dans l'océan
pouvait avoir un effet
sur la hausse des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère.
- Pour moi, ce ne fut pas une
grande surprise de voir que
des gaz à effet de serre sont
produits à partir du plastique.
Ma surprise était que personne
l'avait étudié. Sans doute
que l'industrie du pétrole et
du plastique était au courant,
mais il fallait qu'un
scientifique, à un moment donné,
fasse cette découverte et puis
la publie scientifiquement
afin que ce soit connu.
- Elle et son équipe ont fait
des tests sur le polyéthylène,
la sorte de plastique qu'on
retrouve le plus dans l'océan.
Ils ont démontré que plus
un objet se fragmente,
plus il offre une grande
surface aux rayons du soleil.
Ainsi, il émet davantage de
gaz et devient encore plus
nocif pour l'environnement.
- Comme on sait que le temps
de vie du plastique est énorme,
des centaines d'années, bien,
ce plastique va continuer
à produire ces gaz à effet
de serre sur une échelle
de temps incroyable!
Je crois que l'industrie du
plastique n'a pas tellement
aimé la publication.
J'ai essayé de travailler avec
l'industrie du plastique lors
de mes recherches. J'ai demandé
de l'aide, j'ai essayé d'ouvrir
des portes, discuter avec
l'industrie du plastique, puis
à chaque fois, ils ont fermé
les portes puis ils m'ont dit
qu'ils pouvaient pas avoir
de communication avec moi.
- L'industrie n'a pas de quoi
s'inquiéter. Depuis le début
de la pandémie de COVID-19,
la consommation de plastique
à usage unique aurait augmenté
de 250 à 300 % aux États-Unis
seulement. À l'échelle de la
planète, des chercheurs ont
calculé que la production de
plastique va doubler d'ici
15 ans et quadrupler d'ici 2050.
Plusieurs pensent qu'il est
désormais urgent de revoir
notre mode de vie.
- Pour moi, je trouve qu'on
est complètement démesuré dans
notre consommation de plastique.
Si vous voulez consommer,
consommez avec un esprit vert.
Essayez de réfléchir à votre
impact, à votre footprint :
qu'est-ce que vous laissez
derrière vous quand vous
consommez un produit?
Il faut protéger notre océan.
Il nous amène l'oxygène,
il nous amène une partie
de notre nourriture.
On doit faire attention à ce
qu'on consomme pour s'assurer
que la planète est en santé.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Après la pause : comment
envisager l'avenir des océans?
Est-il trop tard pour sauver les
océans? Un peu partout à travers
le monde, des scientifiques
et des citoyens s'unissent
pour trouver des solutions.
Mais cela prendra des efforts
considérables, notamment pour se
défaire de notre dépendance au
plastique. Il faudra aussi une
volonté ferme des dirigeants de
la planète pour éviter le pire.
- (narrateur): Les océans n'ont
jamais été aussi malmenés et
les conséquences pour l'avenir
de l'humanité se font déjà
sentir. C'est pourquoi les
Nations unies ont proclamé que
cette décennie sera celle des
sciences océaniques au service
du développement durable.
Devant l'urgence, les
scientifiques du monde entier
seront mis à contribution pour
tenter d'inverser le déclin
des océans avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard.
Ce sentiment d'urgence a trouvé
écho à Columbus, en Ohio.
C'est là qu'habite Kathy
Sullivan. L'astronaute et
océanographe nous a donné
rendez-vous au COSI,
le centre de sciences qu'elle
a dirigé et où ses prouesses
sont immortalisées.
- Mes.compadre,  dans la navett,
ont pris cette photo-ci.
- C'est lors de ce vol à bord de
la navette Challenger,  en 1984,
que Kathy Sullivan inscrit
son nom dans le grand livre
de l'aventure aérospatiale
des États-Unis.
- C'est la phrase qui indique
que je suis la première
femme américaine à marcher
dans l'espace.
- Ce n'est qu'un début.
Kathy Sullivan va ensuite
réaliser deux autres missions
spatiales avant d'être nommée
scientifique en chef de la NOAA,
la prestigieuse agence
américaine responsable
de l'étude de l'océan
et de l'atmosphère.
À ce moment, la scientifique
comprend qu'elle peut faire
une réelle différence.
- J'ai senti vraiment que
seulement d'avoir cette
opportunité fantastique de voir
notre planète de ce point de
vue, il faut que je retourne
sur Terre et trouve les moyens
d'emporter cette perspective
aux gens. J'ai dit, en anglais :
«I have to make it matter.»
♪ ♪ ♪
- Mais le goût de l'aventure
n'est jamais bien loin.
En 2020, Kathy Sullivan
est invitée à plonger à bord
d'un submersible dans la fosse
des Mariannes. L'objectif :
descendre jusqu'au point nommé
Challenger Deep, l'endroit le
plus profond jamais mesuré dans
les océans, à plus de 10 900 m
sous le niveau de la mer.
- J'ai lu beaucoup de papiers et
de livres au sujet de Challenger
Deep. Mais d'être là, le voir
moi-même, mes yeux! C'était...
On peut pas résister.
Je peux pas résister.
Bien sûr, j'y vais!
- Elle devient alors
le premier être humain
à avoir marché dans l'espace
et à s'être aussi rendu au point
le plus profond des océans.
Une expédition hors du commun!
- C'est comme un ascenseur.
Quatre heures dans un ascenseur,
sereine, calme. Génial.
- Les rares humains qui
s'aventurent à ces profondeurs
ont droit à tout un spectacle!
- C'est ça qui est, pour moi,
la magie de l'océan : partout
dans l'océan, on trouve la vie.
Toutes les espèces, tous
les types, toutes les formes,
toutes les adaptations de la vie
partout dans l'océan, c'est
un miracle. C'est merveilleux!
Et puis, on est arrivés
sur le fond.
C'était comme le paysage
de la Lune.
- Mais les fosses abyssales
réservent aussi de tristes
surprises.
- On a trouvé le plastique
aux plus profondes régions de
l'océan. On est aux profondeurs
de 11 000 m, au centre de
nowhere,  et quand même, les
déchets humains y sont arrivés.
Partout.
Nous, les hommes, nous sommes
partout sur la Terre. Nous
sommes partout dans l'océan.
- Les humains sont-ils allés
trop loin? Dans son rapport
sur l'océan, le Groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental
sur l'évolution du climat,
le GIEC, croit qu'il est encore
possible de sauver la mise :
L'appel a été entendu.
En Gaspésie, les pêcheurs
sont conscients de l'ampleur
de la tâche, mais ils croient
qu'il est toujours possible
de changer la donne.
- L'avenir des océans, bien,
c'est sûr qu'il va falloir
beaucoup changer nos habitudes
de vie, pas mal tout le monde.
Puis en changeant ça, peut-être
bien que ça va donner un plus.
Puis je te dis pas que, t'sais,
ça va durer encore un million
d'années, mais au moins,
pour le temps que ça va durer,
au moins on va être là pour
faire des efforts puis essayer
de préserver la continuité.
- Partout sur la planète, des
initiatives voient le jour pour
tenter d'enrayer le déclin des
océans. En Floride, par exemple,
des scientifiques ont réussi à
reproduire une espèce de corail
en laboratoire. Ils pensent
être en mesure de restaurer les
récifs de coraux nécessaires
à la vie marine et qui sont
menacés de disparition.
Des programmes de certification
ont été créés ici et ailleurs
pour aider les consommateurs
à choisir des poissons
et des fruits de mer pêchés
ou produits de façon durable.
De nouvelles technologies
sont aussi développées
pour débarrasser les océans
du plastique.
Et partout, des corvées
sont organisées pour nettoyer
les plages et les fonds marins.
À San Diego, en Californie,
l'océanographe Sarah-Jeanne
Royer a justement décidé
de passer à l'action pour
contrer cette pollution causée
par les déchets plastiques.
- Donc ici, on va
sélectionner les petits
bouts de microplastiques.
- Elle et son conjoint élaborent
une application pour téléphone
mobile qui mise sur la
participation citoyenne et
l'intelligence artificielle.
- Les citoyens vont prendre des
photos de bouts de plastique sur
des plages, sur des roches, sur
les zones côtières en général.
Ces photos vont être partagées
avec nous puis, à l'aide de
l'algorithme, on va calculer
les concentrations de plastiques
à travers le monde.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Mais tous ces efforts citoyens
ne seront pas suffisants.
- Il faut que les pays
travaillent ensemble sur un
but commun. Parce que tous ces
problèmes, ils sont plus grands
que chaque pays. Ils sont plus
grands que le plus grand pays!
Il s'agit de toute la planète.
Il faudra l'action commune
de toute l'humanité.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un exemple de ce que peuvent
faire les nations, c'est
la création d'aires marines
protégées. Des zones où
les activités humaines sont
strictement encadrées et où
la pêche est souvent interdite.
- Les aires marines protégées,
une fois qu'elles sont créées,
elles produisent plus de
poissons pour les pêcheurs
qui travaillent dans
les zones non protégées.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose
qui est bien établi partout.
- Il y a encore du travail
à faire. Au Canada et pour
l'ensemble de la planète, moins
de 10 % des zones côtières et
océaniques bénéficient du statut
d'aires marines protégées.
Malgré ces aires protégées,
la pression demeure forte
sur le milieu marin.
À preuve, Ottawa vient
d'autoriser l'industrie
pétrolière à effectuer
40 forages exploratoires en
mer au large de Terre-Neuve.
Une région pourtant reconnue
par l'ONU pour son importance
écologique et biologique.
- Le gouvernement doit
se baser sur la science.
Si un gouvernement ne se base
pas sur la science, c'est le
chaos et rien ne marche. Et
c'est pour ça que les ressources
se cassent la figure partout.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le chaos peut être évité. Des
étoiles aux fosses abyssales,
le parcours de Kathy Sullivan
lui permet de croire en un
avenir meilleur. Et ce sont
les nouvelles générations
qui devront montrer la route.
- Je dirais aux jeunes que votre
créativité, votre intelligence,
votre passion, on en a besoin.
La planète en a besoin.
Et leur dire que toi, tu as
l'occasion... c'est ici que
tu vis. Tu es unifié avec tout
cela, alors tu peux faire une
différence. Il faut vraiment
que tu fasses une différence.
Alors, rêvez et travaillez fort,
et vas-y!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Qui se lance aujourd'hui
en agriculture? Un aperçu...
La semaine prochaine à
l'émission : se lancer en
agriculture, c'est un peu comme
faire un saut dans le vide.
Il faut beaucoup d'audace, de
la volonté et une grande passion
pour le métier. Portraits de
jeunes inspirants qui ont fait
le choix de vivre de la terre.
- J'ai fini le secondaire,
je me suis pas posé de
questions: let's go, on s'en va
à l'ITA à Saint-Hyacinthe.
- Ceux et celles appelés à
renouveler les générations
en agriculture arrivent un peu
bousculés par les attentes
des consommateurs, les grands
accords commerciaux, les normes
sanitaires ou la protection
de l'environnement. Ils joignent
les rangs d'un groupe qui
fait face à d'énormes défis.
- On a confié la production
d'aliments à moins de
1 % de la population!
- Voilà, c'est ainsi que prend
fin notre émission. Merci
d'être fidèle au rendez-vous
et bonne semaine verte!